hello everybody and welcome to part 10
of let's play penumbra overture as you
all know we left off with me making a
fool out of myself with a spider I tried
to whack it in its face but it face
proved elusive oh no human remains oh no
oh no dead end over there okay I know
what the deal is
oh wow hi No what's this look at her ah
highly flammable I know uh I don't I
know
ah ha die spider burn oh oh so smart so
smart oh I think like ten billion miles
an hour
fashion oh you'll find yourself at the
wall look out Billy with a Donnell above
you oh don't carry it in this tunnel for
both our sakes be careful not curious
how do you know where I am
I already spoken to you about the cat oh
I'm glad I brought myself it's not only
down to the question but ah
climbing down the country there are
spiders [ __ ] on us that love to suck on
me oh no no no no no no aah aah what boo
hunky oh I know I know
aah yeah I know now not then not when I
needed to know it duh why were the boars
there so that I could avoid them or move
them sis but no no that's not it that's
not it
oh [ __ ] me oh oh no I'm gonna die again
oh this is so sad Oh sad sad sad sad all
right that happened oh oh how many times
have I got just gonna repeat this until
it stops being entertaining for you guys
just watching me die do you enjoy this
are you not entertained
Yeah right
let me think this through okay big rock
comes here planks of wood important
maybe maybe if I smack them they will
break maybe oh boy oh yeah oh yeah
Oh suck it Boulder yeah Boulder Colorado
no actually if any of you are from
Boulder Colorado I love that place
he's fantastic oh yeah oh yeah that's
the victory spear uh-huh thank you John
oh then I better smack it ah oh boy
oh I shouldn't have done that oh no nope
nope yeah
oh boy this is bad this is bad isn't it
back oh okay this looks bad I feel bad
juju coming up in here uh-huh
oh that's right okay yeah oh yeah look
at me fallin into victory on that ride
oh yeah this looks good glad I'm here
they're happy yes pain-killing is that
red and white cross box in that room
just in case those spiders without your
own flesh delicious in sick how does my
brain flesh know your fluids are leaking
because I read to trick you oh ah [ __ ]
you Billy
oh come on
not cool Billy shut up Billy uh he is
hot and an eight-legged baptismal
fighter
shut up with justice now SAR cold I hope
that we can screw friends o friends so
go choose I'm not friends with anyone
named Billy this unless one of you is
named Billy and you're my best friend my
best friend ever
all right enough Pandaren time to get
real real up in y'all what's going on
ventilation shaft ooh I'll marry you
ah what is this oh shut up John no one
cares about your witty observations only
mine oh it's this as nothing ah okay
moving on
ah another one I can break with my fists
Oh dad oh yeah another one
haha hey yeah Oh [ __ ] got you got you
hardcore get out here get get out of
here
punk punk yeah I didn't even need to
bond you one more time you knew what's
up uh uh yep you're not dead yet thanks
to me you just died like seven times
what does it matter
all right what do we got here Oh a
puzzle I can fear this [ __ ] ah I see it
already I'm so smart okay all right that
does that oh no back a bit oh so so
smart oh yeah guests on the first try oh
oh so smart get down
get down let go ah I will I will cut you
box get off of that box uh yeah oh I
know I know oh so smart
oh now my brain juices are working like
an overtime oh yeah
you're also impressed right now it's
okay hold your applause nah applaud go
ahead and applaud oh wait a blood oh
thank you thank you thank you thank you
who wasn't here ah all yeah a buckle of
my books ah bah blah blah blah blah
halal eat in with Christianity Arctic
communities Oh Oh Carla heck
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba alright and Jack we'd
turn gay tribe shaman cherished a kakuka
I got weeds funny words like oh there's
a message from God
oh thanks God knows no labor by oh well
that's not from
all right let's get this over with yeah
intelligence
I should project put it under it good
idea mark thanks mark a little bit off
so I can jump up it there we go
that's do yeah oh yeah I think this is
quickest I've gone through a puzzle the
whole game so thank you oh yeah
Boeing Boeing Boeing [ __ ] done whack
wrong in booyah Oh victory screen flash
I like it ah don't wanna go there yep
this looks safe
I like this oh yeah
Oh a box I got a box wait what's the
point oh I couldn't get through this
team I get it all your gasoline yeah
according to Billy need a key
I don't need a key I'll just break
through the lock again with my fists
yeah how long could it good logic John
doesn't make any sense does it
oh that's dramatic music I oh that was
bad that made sense how do I get out
here honey how do I get out here oh oh
yeah okay that makes it come here
pallets right make a nice ramp Oh get
out of the way box
I'll get other way box oh yeah [ __ ]
yeah oh I mean I love it hey good come
on
hey mama ah ha ha ha fudge ah
OOP ah potato oh no aah come on I'll be
like that oh why you be like that just
be normal
oh yeah that's normal
no good over there ah no base out a
little bit you too
Oh No come on maybe oh yeah I'm victory
are you okay got the gasoline
now I'm going somewhere else maybe I'll
drop down here oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] ah
door Oh
blocking the door eh you're burning
steam palette ah a burnin steam burn in
steam I'm here I'm here
who's out there who's there okay the gas
was the only thing in the storage room
I think what's up there Oh
secret secret secret give me the secret
yeah give me the secret oh hey I said
give me the secret there we go
nope sorry about that so I'm gonna miss
oh right oh ha some secret
bull Oh what's up their secret house a
secret Oh key ah I would have gone out
of here without the key oh go away hey
get get get out get out of here I don't
care about you posters a playmate where
whoa where's this most room Oh get out
of the way what's going on what is this
screw that that is that is stupid oh
hello hello
gimme gimme gimme ha ha all right
I win I'm the best getting out of here I
think that's everything
all right oh ah
dad the fine all right I'll pause it
here thank you so much for watching and
I will see you in episode 11 bye bye